はぁっ
バーンッ
ふぁーーーっ
はっはっ
4階ですね科学の世界ようこそドクター
始めた私は今からに来ているリバーこんな広いところですることと言えば只一つ
危険な実験だと上で今回用意したのはこちらこれたい大丈夫なのかな俺すごい不安なん
だよねこちらの発行だ
私は正直ビビってる正直言いますがこれやっていいのかちょっとわからない大丈夫だよ
ね大丈夫
歌なぜなんか誰かをケガさせるような場所ではないのでそこは大丈夫だと思います
今回ネットで購入した商品はこちら hydrogen ロケット
水ずロケットです
俺ビックリグミにこれ私は見たときびっくりしたスイスロケットたるものが普通に
ネットで売っているのかというこの真実勝ちだからねこれは大丈夫なのかなー割と本当
に怖いんですけど本当の水素ロケットみたいですあの hydrogen っていうの
は水素の意味ですでロケット
見たサンジなんか見るからヤバそうなんですけどな茎どもが楽しそうにやってるんで
多分大丈夫でしょう
実際にこれを使ってちょっと
水素ロケットパルマの飛ばしてみようと思う二版の水素ロケットいってどんなんだろう
っていう多分ペットボトルロケットと比べても全然威力が強いと思うのでやっていこう
怖いよ a 1ってほんとですねやすい定めたらいいかんだけどオッスクツ買ってき
ましたよ
これが多分ロケットですこれがロケット aoao 英語になっておりますこれ待って
麻雀これ目からね
水素発生しそうな怪しいそうそれはなにこれはこれがたが団地の中にダメロケット入れ
て発射させる感じかなとかここはこれ大丈夫かなちょっとマジもんなんだけどうーん
まあなんかもやばいうんかもうねが色々とやばそうですまあこれ絶対コレだ絶対コレだ
なんだ臼井さんはまあでもれてもれてるんだけどそう怪しい白い粉が入っておりました
匹たりが c とクエン酸のことですねはい
usp どぇ
ジェネレーターの中に先に s ちょっとクール jlg 姉レイプ
俺めっちゃこういう国をリューション作りますまず水204準備でトイレもえっとこの
中にさっきのこのコーナーですクエン酸を入れますよ指導柄ですやアーマー0とスティ
アーだから混ぜます
本家つ完成しました顎へと falling it on the いくにいってとこ
願いグリッターですぐにたーーーーの上まで水が入っちゃうとダメみたいなのでユニ
ダーより下まで開き作ってソリューションを入れます鳥が来たかな
もうちょい i テンダーリングキーまで入りましたこれ燃料の完成みたいで fuel
ジェネレーターでこれの次はここにセットするみたいで
insert フィールディングドラムセットプレー
で起きこれで固定されました次に何柱部分にのせますあぁなんかやガチっぽくなってき
た誰もツイストでロック危ないから離れるな
バジャーするなぁ
気をつけてる
by 場合でここから多分これが待っても蘇武のかなーマジでこれはもう飛ぶ気がして
きた時はロケット実際にここに付けます待ってどうつけるの高普通にもいいを掘る
いやー高は8オンにします
う苛立ちを詰まって本当にやばいあったらこれはた事前血圧いますねにつきましたで何
か作業戦後にランチトーンっていう音が聞こえてくるらしいで本当かなぁ愛というわけ
で一応も準備はできてるみたいでございますまあテープを作っててうんちトーンと
聞こえてこれをプッシュするとも fire するらしいです
今燃料が確実に作られていっております
ありがとうございました
なくなってられ何なりもうまってまってあっ
んランチとンっていう音だったんだねもういけるはずで先のがピーピーピーピー言って
たんででは水素ロケット飛ばしてみようと思いますねー
なんなかったです何でのなかったんだろあの食べる音音が鳴っていた時にはネギいけ
なかったジャックがありますがある
絶対ソウルピピピピって後年かなってる時に押せば多分飛ぶみたい
リセットスイッチ2を面前あっは一番
ok 問題です多分これでもう1回ピーピー鳴ったら行けます
きたっ
つかなじゃあ離れろどうぞクンッ
今だ
おっん
ゴミ不明なゴミ披露込
[音楽]
me
バッハ